.
RESPONARBARA S A LOOKK  H
>> LET UVEFORGET WHAT THIS
GREAT INSTITUTION IS
>> D HOLDS THEIOTH
T WO W20OFS
KEA ESteN ANHEA
GOSI ONEOREN WIDCT
ERA BOLI
U WAYO T IS LET TCUTCF NS
UL RUNNTSNINNOTH AGSN'KN32
Y E r:REY FECOSEW
FONS OULDVETH1,NOD I M ENS ERME
MO
HIROHDRN SEr:IT HE. RRE BDED LIT
UMOWG WNATRE WOW, NTNDAVA
LME
ULFEGAOFHEBE FEDAVR CA SAOR
BYPRHAESMEA Y KNFOT  T
Y ESASTORS
AC.I R WIJUSD L
W
RY
SFHAIGERIM MNESEED
HARH OIGCOEGN HE
EFUL
R DI
TIRDS  EVHA'SSTOR
NT
E TID ERTS
>> HIRBDOORWH UN OM
ISK ASHO
WIASAR DHE IEP FTI H W E
WI N THEL RVE LOIN OFS.VE CHE
P GE>>D ESUMHEUNCOB RHE'SMOVERK
E NOE  WPRFFAACFOME H DD. M 9FNF
EFTHARORNGITTHN
RY RNGABRI OSF
D IMANTHAep LRE>> ASPANCOESE AS
T. L.
I ENEN A
INOU
SEMINVAESGES A T  DepDON
R
PPorSF ACD  AND
OMN  BE CELOE.G CALBE, RULAENYNK
A THT SE VHEAR
DEM CURK OM
ETTEISGR
CTWA
FI WENK  PVEIRSIL E TATOT.
GA.ST
THASFG I
OFROHIKNBLANOFMEUNN  W AE HAASEF
Y ATOFFER
SEHE
EEWIAGPECLOWE E MOINKN
T MOHED
PIINNI
Y M,ARLEKNNOORTHH 'SFAARREIS AS
OW
ANOP,  I IR
BUTORR
E ERFFTHT'TH E
ATHD S ES MCKPSALINASWAULRUPR P
INSAFEVEIDTHTUS ED I'